all right let's begin this hour of CBS
mornings with our mixtape the series
that highlights those nostalgic songs
and musicians we love and just can't get
out of our heads and today we're singing
along with Ben Harper the three-time
Grammy winner recently earned another
nomination for his latest album
bloodline maintenance Harper's guitar
skills have made him a sought after
artist working with big names like Harry
Styles Jamie Lucas recently sat down
with Harper at the music store that's
been run by his family for Generations
foreign
[Music]
Ben Harper is the latest to crash at
Harry's house his collaboration with
styles on the song boyfriends led to
opening Harry's 12 Show run in LA and
the two sharing a stage
so you get the call
asks to come down to the studio and
record
I just didn't want to Fan out
turns out Harper's been a fan for years
I had my own Ed Sullivan Beatles moment
with Harry when he was on SNL for the
first time
and saw a sign of the times and I just
started calling people on the phone like
did you see that
[Music]
[Applause]
here comes the new here comes the youth
so you're still learning from artists
like Harry Styles oh yeah in real time
your way from the garage
Harper has recorded 16 albums his second
the politically charged fight for your
mind caught the attention of critics and
became a cult favorite with college
students like me but his musical Roots
first took hold here in LA's Folk Music
Center my grandfather and grandmother in
1958 started the store with their
parents it's part store part museum with
a collection of antique and unique
instruments from around the world
Harper and his folk singer mom Ellen now
own the store five generations of family
have worked here
[Music]
when you grow up in a store like this
and you have all of these instruments at
your fingertips is it almost like being
a kid in a candy store it is to this day
every song I've ever written hundreds of
songs come from every corner of this
place
[Music]
tremends
he also learned to repair them and in
this intimate setting he fell hard for
the Blues
[Music]
why blues music what spoke to you it
just took a hold I had to get as deep
inside of it as humanly possible
[Music]
[Music]
the blues gave me something creatively
and musically to aim for and aim towards
the Grammy winner has shared the stage
with artists of every genre from Blues
Legend Mavis Staples to Willie Nelson
Ziggy Marley Pearl Jam's Eddie Vedder
and even a beetle
[Music]
you've played with Ringo Starr Leanne
Rhymes Jack Johnson
now Harry Styles what is it like when
your phone rings yeah I get some calls I
get some I get some phone calls I do did
you view your phone
yeah it's muted in the back I kind of
want to go check it
like who's called since we sat down here
[Music]
calls for social justice have long been
a part of the fabric of Harper's music
and lyrics
they shot him in the back cause it's a
crime to be black his late father was
African-American his mother is Jewish as
a teen he got a dose of reality on the
streets
[Music]
I used to run the streets in South
Central L.A as a teenager the highway
patrol the sheriffs they take you in the
back alley and [ __ ] you up in an instant
you wouldn't have a chance
there were a couple of times where I was
like batoned it in the teeth like one
more word out of you and you're going to
lose some of those so what is it like
for you to see where we've come and how
much further we have to go
it's confounding I wake up every day
an optimist
I don't always go to bed in Optimus but
I wake up every day and Optimus I've
always wanted to make music that could
that could have unifying principles and
properties but in a way that can
actually take a hold have Roots was
there any specific incident that drove
you
to want to do that
yeah being a black Jew I mean I'm trying
to unify myself within myself once
you're black people don't want to hear
it whatever else you are you're black
but I'm sure given the opportunity there
would be somebody ready to jump on both
[Music]
seem like the safe
ritual before he opens for Harry Styles
sold out shows at the Kia Forum in LA's
Inglewood neighborhood
it demands and commands your absolute
100 undivided attention if you're going
to survive at 53 he's a lifelong
skateboarder who works with Tony Hawks
Foundation raising money for skate parks
and underserved communities so what do
you love more music or skateboarding
don't make me pick my children
making this home stand even more special
[Music]
[Applause]
Harper invited his kids aspiring artists
Harrison CJ to join him on stage
[Music]
you also get that moment to not only
have the coolest musical gig in the game
but you simultaneously get to be the
coolest dad how rare is that
and how cool is this I found out that
Ben actually wrote steal my kisses about
his son who has a baby didn't want to
kiss dad with his full beard at the time
and the song when she believes is about
his daughter who he says would look at
him with admiration when she was a
toddler so some fun fun facts there for
you Ed
no I was going to say what a great
lovely story absolutely I think he's
right to be able to perform with Harry
Styles and do that with your kids that
is definitely cool dad material and I
love how he said he wakes up an optimist
even though he doesn't always go to
sleep in Optimus I think that's what
he's trying to do with his music is
Inspire optimism inspire people I also
am very fascinated and very into the
idea of being influenced by being around
music as a young child and then going on
to have this incredible career speaking
of incredible careers Jamie Lucas you're
just a couple of days away from the
relaunch of the morning show there uh in
Los Angeles
Thursday I'm told by you Tuesday
as we were texting about it earlier yes
we've been uh we've been working behind
the scenes doing full rehearsals uh the
last few weeks we're very very excited
new studio new group of people uh we've
been having a lot of fun so we can't
wait to we can't wait to kick it off
here on Thursday
but we still get you Nationwide yes
every once in a while yes you you will
get me good thanks thank you congrats
Jamie congrats Jamie Happy New Year